-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-That was you -- that was you
and Cedric the Entertainer
right there.
-It was, and it's funny.
It's a very serious
and somber movie
that I love, but it is hard
to find a funny moment,
and you found it.
-Yeah. We found the one,
because this is not --
-Yeah, yeah, mined it out.
-Do not let the presence
of Cedric the Entertainer
lead you astray.
This a very serious movie.
You play a priest
in upstate New York.
-Right.
-A small -- in a small church
who is having a crisis of faith.
-Exactly.
-Yeah, whereabouts
does the crisis come from?
-It comes from counseling
a young man who is experiencing
severe depression about what's
happening with the environment.
And I play this priest
who takes his crisis
really seriously,
and hilarity begins there.
[ Both laugh ]
Laughs ensue.
No, it's a brilliant movie.
It's written by the guy
who wrote "Taxi Driver"
and "Raging Bull,"
Paul Schrader.
-Paul Schrader, yeah.
-He's a brilliant director,
and when I read it,
it was one of these scripts
where he's just giving voice
to something that I think
a lot of people are feeling
right now -- a level of anxiety
about our leadership
and about our faith
and where it intersects with
love and what we are doing,
and it was --
It blew me away when I read it.
And, so, it's an honor
to be here.
-And you play a priest
in this film.
You actually had family
in your life who thought
that would be a good career path
for you.
Actual priesthood.
-Yeah, my great grandmother
thought that --
she felt certain when I was born
that I would receive
the calling.
-Oh, wow.
-And I would be a priest.
And I remember
being very concerned,
"What is this thing,
the calling?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Well, God will come to you,
and tell you, and I was like,
"Okay. I do not want
that to happen."
[ Laughter ]
"When will that happen?"
"Well, in silence."
Okay, I'm avoiding silence
at all costs.
And I was so happy
when she kind of decided that,
well, my calling was the arts.
-That's good.
-But I did, when I put
the collar on the first time,
I thought of her, and thought,
"Hey, grandma, I'm back."
-There you go.
"I got the calling."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's very -- I think she
would be sad that the calling
came from your agent.
[ Laughter ]
"Big news, Ethan,
you're a priest!"
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-Were your parents --
when -- you know obviously,
you found your way to the arts
at a young age,
were they supportive
of this idea
of you trying to be to actor?
-Well, you have to understand
that my father is an actuary.
-Okay.
-He's a mathematician.
He's -- like one of the few jobs
in the world that really uses
calculus. You know?
So when I told him
that I wanted to be an actor,
he felt the need to lay out
the actuarial tables
on that succeeding.
You know, like, let's do
the math on how many guys
in the Screen Actors Guild
make more than $17,000 a year.
And making sure
before I chose it,
and I decided I was okay
with that.
-Okay, that's good.
-The odds were not good,
but I was all right with that.
-And you got into it --
You got into it very young.
-Yes.
-And now, I mean,
I've certainly have been aware
of you --
-Is this conversation
going to how old I am?
Is that where we're headed?
[ Laughter ]
-But I'm starting
at the young part.
We're going to get there.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-But you've come to
the conclusion, I've heard,
that there are now parts
that you have aged out of?
-Well, it's awful to realize
that you're no longer
going to star in sports movies.
-Yeah.
-You know, I used to always --
I used to always tell myself,
"I'll get in shape
when I get that part," you know,
where I play a boxer.
-Yeah, right.
-I'll get in shape
when I'm playing an NBA guy.
And you're like, okay,
that's not happening.
I even had the thought --
this was a couple years now,
but when Brett Favre retired,
I was like, "Oh, you know what?
I like Brett Favre. I could
really play him in a movie."
I'm like "No, I'm older
than Brett Favre.
I'm older than guys
who are retiring."
-Yeah, yeah.
-That doesn't feel good.
But I am, you know -- I'm
putting on my coach face soon.
-I think,
I'm not sure about this,
but I once hosted
an awards show,
the ESPYs,
and I was making jokes
about how old Brett Favre was.
And he pointed out to me
afterwards like, he's like,
"I'm like a year older
than you."
[ Laughter ]
Like stop acting like
such a hot shot.
-I know. I know.
We think that --
We expect so much
from our athletes.
-Yeah.
-We really do.